mad about you star Helen Hunt rushed to
the hospital on a stretcher and Kevin
Frazier's on the scene we have the video
and new details about Helens frightening
car crash exclusive video obtained by ET
shows Helen being loaded into an
ambulance after yesterday's terrifying
rollover crash this really is one of
LA's busiest intersections and there are
still remnants in the street today of
the violent collision that left Helen
Hunt's chauffeured SUV on its side in
the security camera footage at the top
of your screen you can see the black SUV
take a left
then it's t-boned by an oncoming white
sedan the violent impact flipped the SUV
over onto its left side trapping Helen
inside closest to the scene were the
employees at this Jiffy Lube
they came outside they saw the SUV
smoking and that's when the hero sprung
into action bikes one of my helpers to
help me up on top of the car
I opted upright the door opened I just
seen three people on side I just
immediately out of my instinct up them
up helped them out of the car did you
realize that you were helping a
Hollywood star I didn't know that I was
hoping a star my first instinct was just
get everybody outside this out
there's the Oscar winner sitting up and
strapped to a stretcher before being
rushed to the hospital because when did
you realize who it was just now just now
et has learned Helen who was shooting
her mad about you revival with co-star
Paul Reiser has no major injuries and is
now at home recovery and we've also
learned that production on mad about you
will continue as Helen recovers
[Music]
[Applause]